pasaron ocho meses desde el fin de la
última guerra de henao no cara para a
partir del cual se intensificó la
atención política como así también la
polarización social en el país a raíz de
esto hoy se celebran elecciones
parlamentarias anticipadas en las que 26
partidos y fuerzas políticas disputan
las bancas de la asamblea nacional de
armilla según las encuestas las
facciones que lideran estas elecciones
son la colisión a armenia encabezada por
el ex presidente robert kocharián y el
partido oficialista contrato cívico del
primer ministro interino en nicole
pazzini a estas facciones deben obtener
por lo menos el 51 por ciento de los
votos por lo contrario habría
posibilidades de una segunda vuelta por
otro lado es importante mencionar la
significativa cantidad de ciudadanos
indecisos en trajes
y asciende al 30% y otros que han
decidido no ocultar
la jornada comenzó a las 8 de la mañana
y transcurre establemente a pesar de las
denuncias de ciertas irregularidades que
ocurrieron en los colegios electorales
por el momento alrededor de un 20% de la
población ejerció su derecho al voto y
aquellos que no lo hicieron pueden
hacerlo hasta el 20 del horario local